en 2013 vous aviez créé des pin's où
vous étiez engagé à créer un million
d'emplois en 5 ans pas engagé pas engagé
objectif moi je vous respecte parce que
vous avez pas dit quel pays donc ça
jusque là c'est
compris
et maintenant voici mon stagiaire tome
villa merci
quel plaisir de travailler
merci patron
ah ça fait plaisir merci bah oui mais
vous serez d'accord avec moi je suis sûr
monsieur Gattaz que il y a plein de
stagiaires qui aiment leur patron ça
doit exister oui vous allez a l'air de
douter vous-même
j'espère non mais oui et puis des
patrons qui qui payent leur stagiaires
ce soir sur le plateau que des invités
qui représentent piriata c'est le
patronat Natoo les youtubeurs ils vend
le bolloc' les les cheveux gras mi-longs
et non
pierre Gattaz pierre le patron des
patrons si vous avez de la musique on
aurait eu Johnny dommage on a pire
iatase non mais vous avez beaucoup de
points communs avec Johnny monsieur
Gattaz la moindre apparition publique
suscite des hurlements des pleurs des
mouvements de foule bon sauf que Johnny
c'est pour lui faire des câlins vous
voilà et non vous avez vous avez une
très bonne tête c'est vrai il a l'air
on lui donnerait des stocks
alors pierre vous êtes le président du
Medef alors le Medef qu'est-ce que c'est
c'est le mouvement des entreprises de
France une sorte de CGT pour les mecs
qui payent l'ISF
non mais c'est vrai eux quand ils
mangent les merguez elles sont fourrés
au foie gras
en tout cas non mais c'est vrai on a
plus l'image du patron ai par ses
employés alors qu'il y a des employés
qui aiment leur patron comme moi par
exemple j'aime mon patron voilà quand il
y a un problème j'en parle à Thierry
directement il est accessible il est à
l'écoute de bons conseils par exemple il
m'a conseillé de jamais demander
d'augmentation
et je les fais et ça fait un an
en tout cas pierre gataz en 2013 vous
aviez créé des pin's où vous étiez
engagé à créer un million d'emplois en 5
ans pas engagé pas engagé objectif moi
je vous respecte parce que vous avez pas
dit quel pays donc ça jusque là c'est
vrai
professions fait des vidéos sur Internet
origine polonaise hébergement YouTube
très important parce que sur youporn
vous auriez pas été invité à saluer les
Terriens mais dans zéro limite la
prochaine émission de Thierry sur D8
Natoo en moyenne vous faites entre 5 et
6 millions de vues par vidéo
pour vous donner un ordre d'idée pierre
c'est l'équivalent du nombre de chômeurs
en France voilà ce qui est sur Youtube
on peut pas trafiquer les chiffres
et puis on emmerde toujours les
youtubeurs parce qu'il gagne de l'argent
en faisant des vidéos mais c'est normal
en fait tu vois c'est sur Youtube en
gros vous gagnez 1000 euros du million
de vues mais si vous gagnez de l'argent
c'est que vous le méritez sincèrement tu
as imaginé si on faisait ça à la télé
1000 euros du million de téléspectateurs
il y en a beaucoup qui seraient au Rémi
ça
d'ailleurs vous aviez dit vous en aviez
marre des journalistes qui vous posent
toujours la question de combien vous
gagnez et je suis d'accord voilà du coup
vous gagnez combien sinon
Yvan Le bolloc
le premier Giton voilà mélange de gitan
et de Breton crepo
hérisson chouchen 95 et du chouchen au
sans plomb et mais pas de Vannes sur les
Bretons moi j'ai un quart breton Thierry
et voilà c'était ma grand-mère
maternelle qui était alcoolique et en
tout cas pas d'amalgame sur les gitans
je vous jure les gitans c'est des gens
gentil si c'est des connards qui font à
bouffer dans une caravane c'est pas des
gitans c'est des bobos dans un food
truck rien à voir
ils vend le bolloc c'est un peu notre
George Clooney français comédien beau
gosse en vieillissant s'est fait des
couilles en or avec le café
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser pierre Gattaz je vous dites qu'en
France le coût du travail est encore
trop cher à part naturaliser des Chinois
vous proposer quoi
mais c'est pas le c'est pas le salaire
net qui est embêtant ce sont les charges
que nous prenons sur le coup du travail
sinon moi je vais me proposition faites
comme Thierry payer au black puis voilà
c'est la main noire
Natoo Natoo vous avez 31 ans ce qui fait
de vous l'une des doyennes de YouTube ça
fait quoi d'être la ligne Renault
d'Internet
faudrait vite que je me fasse un petit
lifting pour durer encore plus longtemps
et pour terminer ils vont le bologue ils
vont vous avez dit je veux être là où on
ne m'attend pas ça veut dire que le 6
mai prochain vous serez au côté de
Marine Le Pen
ah bah ça tu peux toujours te brosser
mon petit garçon
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu